This video is made possible by Vince.
Sarah watches luxury handcrafted watchers,
a fair prices.
You can check the mouths of INSERRA
watches.com forward slash biographics
there's also a link below
his writings inspired
the great revolutionary
movements of the 20th century
leading to the dictatorial rise of men
like Joseph Stalin and Mouser Dong.
He lived a life of poverty and obscurity.
Contends let others take the limelight
and aware that his ideas would not be
realized during his lifetime. We
remember him as the father of communism,
yet the version that took hold in
the Soviet Union and China or little
resemblance to what he had envisioned.
In this week's biographics,
we discovered the man who was Karl Marx.
Okay.
Comox was born on May the fifth 1818
and the historic German town of Tria.
His was an upper middle
class family with his father,
Heinrich are doing well as a lawyer
cause mother Henrietta was from a wealthy
Dutch family.
The family was Jewish,
but Heinrich had converted to Christianity
the year before Cole was born in
order to avoid the harsh laws
that were being imposed upon Jews.
Cole was the third of nine children.
He became the eldest son when his brother
Bart's died in 1919 the young call was
a lively child who was prone
to getting into trouble.
He was homeschooled by his father to the
age of 12 at which point he entered the
tree. Our high school, the headmaster
of the school, Hugo Whitson Bark,
took an instant liking to the inquisitive
young Marx and helped him to mold his
early philosophical ideas,
which mark taught liberal ideas to a
students and employed a young liberal
humanists as teachers.
As a result,
the school develops a reputation as
a fermenter of dangerous ideologies.
In 1832 where's embark was placed under
surveillance by the authorities with the
school being searched
for subversive materials.
Call graduated from the school at the age
of 17 he furthered his studies at Bond
University and rolling as law students
in October of 1835 he found the workload
during his first semester to be extremely
challenging by the beginning of 1836
years. Originalist his
attendance to a part time level.
He spent most nights at local pubs in
often woke the next day with a hangover
limiting the amount of focus that
he could give to his studies.
On one occasion he was actually
arrested for public intoxication.
After a year of wasting his efforts at
the University of Bonn marks his father,
he put his foot down.
He transferred his wayward son to the
University of Berlin and ordered him to
start getting serious about his education.
The summer before he transferred
to Berlin University,
cold returned home to triad.
He began to romance with a
young woman called Jenny Vaughn.
West fallen who he had known since
childhood before leaving for university in
October called proposed
and the two were engaged.
The move to Berlin University has served
the purpose of encouraging marks to get
serious about his studies.
He replaced late night carousing with
membership and the of philosophical
societies. He became interested in
the ideas of German philosopher,
Gwf Heagle and the idea is that he Moldova
Sora expression in a number of essays
and treatises that he began working
on calls Brian Academic Star.
It was diminished in May of 1838
with the death of his father.
He had a great deal of respect and love.
The Heinrich ans was
shattered by his loss.
His father had been supporting him
financially and the sudden loss of this
support imposed a
financial hardship on him.
This was a great consent and the West
fallen so when now convinced that call
would not be able to support
their daughter as his
bright, but the young couple,
they continued that courtship even though
they were far away from each other.
Okay.
Following his father's death mocks shifted
the focus of his studies from law to
philosophy.
His goal was to graduate with honors
and then secure a position at the
university as a philosophy lecturer
in order to help fund his studies.
He sought work as a journalist.
He secured a position with the most
controversial newspaper in the region,
the Rhineland News,
the paper expressed vocal opposition to
the Prussian occupation of the Ryman.
In October of 1842 Karl Marx became
the editor in chief of the paper.
It was through this paper.
The marks began writing about communism
and what form of possible communist
government could take,
but when he openly criticized
the Russian monarchs on Nicholas,
the first there was a step too far.
The brushing authorities
moved in and they shut down.
The paper box was now an
unemployed journalists,
but that didn't stop him and Jenny
marrying on June the 19th 18 at 43 does
ceremony took place in a Protestant
church and was attended by members of both
families though many of the
West filing plan mustards,
there's Jenny was marrying
below her station. However,
the marriage it was to last the couple
until they were potted by death.
Colin, Jenny, they moved
in with Jenny's mother.
They lived off the mother's
step and does color.
Tried to restart his writing career.
He managed to get a writing gig writing
for a newspaper called the Deutsche
Franz Usha Yaba heard that had as its
audience far leftists in the Rhineland.
The paper that had been started
by German Socialist Arnold Ruiz,
who was based in Paris in
October of 1843 marks his wife,
they moved to Paris and
bordered with region. His wife.
In 1844 Jenny gave birth
to their first Charles.
There's made the living conditions
extremely crammed and so the marketers,
they moved into their own
apartments as well as publishing.
The newspaper marks and
rouge worked together on two
treatises that would become
very controversial. The seconds of them
was called on the Jewish question evenly.
Marx was of Jewish ancestry himself.
The pamphlet comes across
as quite antisemitic in as
he wrote for the first time
if the proletariat,
so working class bands of revolutionaries
who would throw off the yoke of
religion and other cultural bonds
to finally unite the masses.
Soon after Mark's moved on from working
with rouge defined employments with the
Paris based newspaper,
four watts or forward,
which targeted Germans living in France
that ava was sponsored by the League of
the just made up of German immigrants
who believed in a communist system where
everyone enjoyed economic equality.
It was while working for Volvo,
it's that Mark's maps since
forms an alliance with
Friedrich Engels, the two men.
They immediately jelled with their ideas
converging into what would be cool to
classical Marxism. Marx was inspired by
a report that angles had written goals,
the conditions of the
working class in England.
He was convinced more than
ever that the working class,
which eventually rise up and
overthrow their oppressors angles,
came from a wealthy family and over
the years he would prop up Mark's
financially time and time again.
They're revolutionary ideas that mocks
was espousing through his writing.
Soon came to the attention of the Prussian
authorities who put pressure on him
to be France.
The interior ministry,
it's shut down votes and mocks was
given 24 hours to leave the country.
He decided to relocate to Brussels,
Belgium with his wife and baby
joining him a few days later.
Belgium was a liberal and free thinking
country and so it was a natural fit for
the leftest philosophies of called mocks,
so you don't have to assess.
I think in Brussels,
Jenny became pregnant with the
couple's second child back in Germany.
Marks in mother-in-law became concerned
that her daughter wouldn't be able to
cope with the stress of starting a new
with one small child and another one on
the way she sends them. Made Seven Helen
de Muth to Russell's to help her cope.
Helen would from then on be a permanent
member of the marks households and known
to Marx.
The Prussian government was putting
pressure on the Belgians to kick him out.
As a result,
he experienced frustrating delays in his
efforts to obtain permanent residency
in order to get residency grounds that
he had to promise not to get involved in
local political issues or a
spouse's pendant school views.
He then proceeded to find loopholes that
would allow him to spread his ideas.
In 1847 he published a treatise
entitled the poverty of Philosophy,
which challenged in early
attract by French leftist
Piaget CF Pruett Hall cooled
the philosophy of poverty.
The poverty of philosophy was a stepping
stone towards Marx's most impressive
and famous work,
the communist manifesto.
In order to get direct experience of
the conditions of the working class,
he traveled to England in 1845
along with Friedrich Engels.
They taught factories and slums witnessing
the terrible working conditions and
the even worse living conditions.
After six weeks in England's marks
returns Brussels fully equipped to produce
his magnum opus. Two weeks
later, the 30 page pamphlet,
it was ready for the presses.
The communist manifesto was published
on February the 21st 1848 in it's mock
stated that the boards want to see where
their own grave diggers with they're
exploited workers, rising
ops, whoever, throw them.
Soon after the manifestos publication,
the second French revolt broke out.
The Monica was cast aside
in the democratic government
was put in place back in
Belgium. Mark's was arrested for sub
lessee of activity. Upon his release,
he made the decision to head to
a reinvigorated and Frea France.
The modern families relocation was helped
by the belated that he received from
his father's estate.
Most of that money though,
was poured into starting
another newspaper.
This newspaper was called the Noya
Reinsch Zeitung angles worked on the paper
providing the latest news and happenings
from Europe so you don't have to.
Moving to France marks
joins the communist league,
which had been formed by members of the
Jak among club after the revolution in
order to prevent the aristocracy
from reasserting itself.
That methods of doing so well,
so drastic that the time period it
became known as the reign of terror.
The French authorities viewed
the Communist League as
the re-instituted Jacobin
Club of just under a new name. This
brought official scrutiny upon the league.
With Mark's being arrested several times.
Initially the police were unable to
direct city Lincoln to any subversive
activity and no prosecution
was brought against him,
but things changed when the Prussian
King Frederick William the fourth took a
personal interest in stomping out
every leftist movement in Israel.
It didn't take long phase attention to
go to the Paris based leftist newspaper
run by call marks for the second time in
his life. He was expelled from France.
Logs had pulled all of his
financial results is into
the paper with it shut down.
He was left with nothing. He only has
enough money to get out of France,
had to visit a porn shop and
Hawk his family's silver.
He received support from a couple of
German socialists to raise money to help
get marks reestablished. However, the help
center down to be a double edge sword,
the benefactors of painted marks to be
in such a poor demoralized condition in
order to scale support that color was
treated as a laughingstock when he
returned. Mark's was not
pleased with this reception.
He stated that the greatest financial
difficulties are preferable to public
begging. Now, just before
we get into monks is moved
to London in his later life.
I want to tell you a bit about today's
sponsor and that's been Sarah watchers.
I'm wearing of INSERRA watch right now.
This is a Vin,
Sarah chronic often as well as keeping
perfect time. It's also got a time.
You see the three battles there.
They look great,
but they also serve the timer function
I picked down to watch with blue and
silver, but they're all loads
of options on their websites.
You'll be sure to find something that
suits your style and your risk size.
As I mentioned before,
I have tightness or risk.
Say they even sorted me out with a
smaller model and it fits perfectly.
I've had this watch for a few months.
I took it on holiday with me.
I've been putting it through its
paces and now I am not a supercap.
We'll watch owner say the least, but it
still looks in great condition. Vince,
Sarah Watches belief that luxury is
all about price or specification.
It's about detail and craftsmanship
and they'd been Saturday or watches.
They've got a ton of that.
Unlike many other watches on the market
and Sarah isn't about minimalist style.
It's about the classic
good look of a watch,
which is something that I personally love.
This is what really sets
it apart from others.
Feather by selling direct to the
consumer of INSERRA can deliver.
A Great Watch is about a 10th of
the price that you might expect.
Go check out the full range of and
Sarah watches.com forward slash and
biographics and use the code biographics
on checkout for a special discounts and
to help support this show.
Let's get back to Mark's
in June of 1849 the Mars family or fought?
Relocated. Yes. Again, the destination.
This time it was London,
England.
It was that final move with a famous
German spending the rest of his life
amongst the English. Not long after
the marks is settled in London,
the disbanded French Communist
league reformed in the city,
the leaders of the movements wanting to
bring about an immediate revolt of the
working classes in London,
which would ideally then spread it across
the entire continent box viewed these
goals as unrealistic and labeled the
leaders of the communist league as
unrealistic dreamers. He was firmly
convinced that the overthrow would come,
but believed that it
had to evolve gradually.
He wasn't even concerned if the revolution
didn't come in his own lifetime.
He was happy to plant the seeds but
would come to fruition at a later time.
As it turned out,
the first communist revolution that didn't
happen for another 68 years in London,
Mark's focused on bringing
reforms on a smaller scale.
He champions the rights of the poor and
advocated for voting rights and freedom
of speech.
For the first few months in London,
the marks family were among the poor
of London only surviving thanks to the
financial support provided by
Friedrich Engels, the financial strain.
It was lifted in 1851 when mark secured
a position as a European correspondent.
For the New York Daily Tribune at the
stoss and goals had to translate the
articles that Marx wrote before.
Long call taught himself English and
was able to translate for himself.
At the time,
the New York Daily Tribune was the most
widely read newspaper and all of the
United States.
The paper paid him 200 pounds per year in
order to provide two articles per week.
Still, it was never quite enough and
the family struggled to make ends meet.
In 1852 marks was concerned with what
was taking place across the English
Channel. The second French Revolution
had erupted and a new Napoleon,
the nephew of the first seized power
establishing itself as the new emperor
longs was frustrated at how the French
working people goods allow another
dictator to rule over them.
He wrote a book,
calls the 18th Broomer of Louis Napoleon,
which mocks the new emperor
in as he placed the blame
on both the French working
class of being sucked in by the dictator
and on the proletariats being gullible
to Napoleon's promise to keep
the masses in check and his book,
he summed it up this way.
The struggle seems to be settled in
central way that all classes equally
impotence and equally remote fall on
their knees before the rifle butts.
As a correspondent for the
New York Daily Tribune,
Marx was in a unique position to give
an outside perspective on the American
civil war.
He predicted that the election of
Abraham Lincoln would lead to civil war,
that the war would greatly impacts the
British economy with its textile industry.
Relying on exports of cotton
from the American south.
He was right on both counts with the
slowdown in trade being at times the cost
and the famine.
Many British factory workers lost their
jobs providing the British government.
We have the incentive to provide financial
aid to prop up the confederate cause
Mark's was quick to point out the
hypocrisy in Britain's position.
Having outlawed slavery itself.
Person was now supporting the slave owning
southern states in order to boost our
own economy. Is articles published
in the Tribune without the,
until the paper changed its pro
abolitionist stance and again,
calling for an immediate cessation
of hostilities from now on,
articles tend to be neutral in that tone.
This was a disaster from mark,
so you run willing to
compromise his principles,
tendered his resignation once more.
Karl Marx was unemployed.
It was terrible timing with financial
pressures having mounds it even before his
leaving the paper.
On top of that,
Jenny was sick with about of a
small box with nowhere else to turn.
Box sought relief from Friedrich Engels.
However,
Bengals was grieving the recent death of
his wife and that has it from cholera.
Requesting relief was not taken kindly.
After three days of stewing on the matter,
he sent the following reply,
you will find it natural.
That's my own trouble and your frosty
reception of it made it positively
impossible for [inaudible] all my friends,
if Shane me on this occasion,
which was bound to touch me very nearly
more sympathy and friendship than I
could expect.
You found the moment suitable to enforce
the superiority of your cold thought
processes.
Mark's was surprised and upset that
he had unwittingly insulted angles.
He quickly wrote back and the process
giving us insight into just how desperate
to situation was wrote.
My wife and children will bend the
witness that when you'll let it came.
I was much shattered by the death
is one of those nearest to me,
but when I wrote to you in the evening,
which was under the impression
of very desperate conditions,
I had the landlord's broker in the house,
the butcher protesting my cheque shortage
of coals and foods and there's little
Jenny in bed in such second senses.
I can generally save
myself only by cynicism.
The two men quickly made up and then
goes once more provided financial support
to keep the marks family
afloat. Before long. However,
Mark's faced a new crisis while his
wife's health improved has earned again to
deteriorate.
Suppose the rubs it all over his body.
You causing great pain and discomfort he
suffered on as he completed his latest
work does capital. The work was
published in Berlin in 1867 and it's,
he emphasized the surplus value of Labor
into the impact of that machines would
have on the workforce.
Does capital was a success,
but that didn't translate to financial
stability for the ever a struggling
family walks.
His mother once made the saint and
comments if only Carl had made capital
instead of just writing about it.
When Mark's,
his daughter Laura got engaged to a
struggling medical students named Paul the
fog.
Have protective father sought to save
her from the same mistake her mother had
made marrying a man who was
ill prepared to Katha hot.
He strongly objected to the marriage only
relenting when he gains the assurance
that the young man was able to
care for his daughter financially.
By 1869 marks was actively working as
an ambassador for an organization called
international working man's association,
which endeavored to bring the world
of communism together under a single
umbrella.
In 1870 France declared war on Germany
among the international working men's
association that was a division between
those who are in favor of the war and
those who were against it.
Mark's was keying for Germany to give the
Frederick good drubbing believing that
it would lead to the resurgence
of socialism in France
following the defeat of
Napoleon. The third a coalition
of international workers,
members and French citizens combined
state control of Paris. After two months,
they were overthrown by the French
authorities. In our short period of time,
mark saw the embodiments
of his proletarian revolt.
It's overthrown by the establishment,
convinced him that the working class
cannot simply lay hold of ready made state
machinery and wield it for its own
purposes for a takeover of power to be
successful marks reasons there had to
be an existing infrastructure ready to
replace the old one.
For the last decade of his life,
Comark struggled with health problems and
financial survival. During this period.
He produced just one work of note in
which he commented on what he terms the
dictatorship of the proletariat.
He expressed his firm belief that the
mass is needed to work together in the
coming revolution without allowing for a
dominant leader to rise. Unfortunately,
that is precisely what happens in many
of the Communist revolutions of the 20th
century. On December the second 1891
Carl's lifelong companion Jenny died.
She had been in terrible pain with
cancer of the liver for months.
Her last words to call or good indicating
that she was happy that her pain was
it an end following Jenny's death marks
fell into a deep depression at the
prompting of his lifelong
friend and Friedrich Engels.
He took a holiday to Algiers.
After two months,
he returned to England just as he was
beginning to get back on his feet.
He received another blow when his daughter
Jenny Caroline died of bladder cancer
at the age of 38 with the loss of his to
Jenny's Marx gave up the will to live.
He hung on for another two months
racked by pain and living in poverty.
The end game on March the 14th 1883
when his bodies to come and to do a
combination of bronchitis and pleurisy.
The man was gone,
but his ideas continues and they had a
massive impact on the coming century.
So I already hope you found this
video. Interesting. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe. Also,
check out our fantastic
sponsors and Sarah watchers.
You'll find a link to them below, and
as always, thank you for watching.
Okay.